INSTRUCTOR: Hi,
data 2100 students.
I'm excited for you to work
on programming in this course.
Now, as a reminder, we are
staying at the very basic level
here.
We're going to start from the
very basic and work our way up.
So if you have no prior
experience in programming,
don't worry about it,
I promise that we're
going to build the building
blocks of programming
along the way and just go slow.
So please don't be too worried
and follow along here with me.
So remember, a
program is a sequence
of instructions that specifies
how to perform some computation.
So this consists of inputs,
outputs, actions, decisions,
and some beginnings and endings.
Basically, in other
words, a process
that can be diagrammed with
a flowchart is a program.
So programming languages
are the same but different.
If this analogy helps
you, then that's great.
For me, it doesn't do much, I've
never seen Lord of the Rings.
[LAUGHTER] I haven't seen most
popular movies or just really
movies in general.
So it's one of my quirky things
about me, but there you go.
So hopefully this
is helpful to you.
But there's a variety of
different programming languages
like C#, C++ Python.
We're going to learn
Python in this course.
So there are different types
of programming languages,
there's basically high level and
low level programming languages
if you will.
And within those there's
object-oriented, specifically
at the high level
and procedural.
Python is an object-oriented
programming language.
So we are going to be at the
higher level, what this means is
the closer we get
to that hardware
or that lower level, the more
similar our program becomes
or the text of our program
becomes to machine language.
So harder for us to
interpret as programmers
and easier for the
hardware to interpret.
So again, the lower
level that we go,
the harder it is for us to
interpret as programmers
and the easier it
is for the computer.
However, at the high level,
it's very easy for us
to interpret as
programmers, but it just
takes some time to get down into
that hardware type of language.
So there's some processes that
must go to, to get to that step.
So Python is an
interpreted, interactive,
and object-oriented
programmer language.
So basically, we have the
source code, which is the code
that we write, and
then there's a compiler
transforms it into bytecode.
Then there's a Python
virtual machine,
and then it may accept input
and maybe some library modules,
and then the code gets executed.
So basically, what this means
is that we write Python code
up here in a language that
US programmers can understand
a little bit easier and it goes
through all of these processes
before the code gets executed.
So just keep that
in mind, you're
not going to be tested on that.
That's just for you to know that
there's lots of in the Python
interpreter stage, there's
lots of things going on
to make it so that, that
language that we're originally
writing transforms into
something that's easily
executable by the machine.
So why Python?
Why are we teaching Python?
If we have all these other
programming languages,
why Python?
Number one it's
good for beginners.
It enforces structures,
it simplifies
some things in reasonable ways.
It's a lot easier to read
and interpret than others.
It's becoming more and more
popular in business applications
and thus in the job market.
It is the standard language for
data manipulation and analysis.
So it is a beginner
programming language,
but it is an
industry level tool.
So it's beginner
programming language,
yet it's used in
industry all the time.
So it's a benefit of both.
As you're in this
data 2100 class,
you are going to be learning
this industry level language
and it's easy to interpret,
to read, and to write.
So why everyone in your company
needs to learn how to code
and how to help them?
Python can be used
for many purposes,
from web development to mobile
app development to data science.
Why learn Python?
Six reasons it's
so hot right now.
So this is another version
of that how coding works
from a certain perspective.
Again, we have a Python code
that comes in that we write.
There's a syntax
checker and translator.
If there is a syntax error
message, it will output to us,
it's very similar to SQL.
Then it's transferred into that
bytecode that we just looked at.
User inputs are then obtained,
it's put in the Python
virtual machine, if you will.
And if there's errors
with the inputs
that we're requesting,
whether we're requesting users
to enter their first and last
name, what have you, then
maybe some error messages
will occur with those inputs.
Then finally, the
program outputs
whatever it needs to based upon
our program itself and the fact
that there has not been
other error messages.
Now, there's a lot of different
programming languages,
but we're going to look at
how do we print, "it's a trap"
by language.
So with Python, it would
be print, it's a trap.
We have our opening
and closing parentheses
and our double quotation marks
around this literal value
of it's a trap.
Perl would look like
this, Java, yikes,
this is going to look
something like that,
and C++ is going to look
something like that.
So they all can
do the same thing,
but Python as you can see
here, it's very interpretable,
and again, it's
used in industry.
But where do we write
our Python code?
This is something that
oftentimes is really confusing
for students and I
totally understand.
So the integrated
development environment
is where we code
our Python programs.
These are basically
software applications,
think of it like a Word document
that programmers write, modify,
debug, and deploy their code.
So these can look like Spider,
like PyCharm, Jupyter Notebooks,
Anaconda, if you will.
So there's a lot of different
integrated development
environments.
You're still writing
the same Python code,
you're just writing it in
a different environment.
So we are actually going to
be using Google Colab which
is a Jupyter
Notebook, so back here
a little bit, Jupyter Notebook
that is hosted by Google,
if you will.
So it's called Google
Colab, it is free
and it's a great resource
for our students.
So we're going to utilize
it, and it's cloud-based.
So there's no need to install
anything which is great.
We don't want to
be in the business
of having to troubleshoot
our installs a lot.
So that's why we're going
to use Google Colab.
So let's take a look
at our Google Colab.
So if I come over here, so I go
to My Drive and I can see here
I have my Colab notebooks.
You have this as well because
you installed Google Colab.
Sorry, you install Google Colab
with our installing assignment.
And then what it did is it auto
created this Colab notebooks
folder here for you.
You'll see that
this one is labeled
sigurd_accessinggooglecolab.
So now I'm going to
create a new Google Colab.
So you see how I come
over here, actually,
I'll do it within
this Colab notebooks.
Let's right click, Go More
and then Google Colab.
So over here this is
where we name our--
so this is a Jupyter
Notebook file.
This is where we're going
to be writing and running
our Python program.
So let's just name
this Python demo.
I'm not going to be asking
you to turn this in,
this is just to get
you acquainted with it.
So if I look here,
I can add code
or I can add text here to
my Jupyter Notebook file.
So if I click Add
text then I can
say this is actually
using Markdown language.
So you can google
Markdown language,
but basically a heading
would be one hashtag,
this is a heading for example,
and then it will populate that.
But if I just wanted to
have normal comment here,
I could say, this
is a Python demo,
and then it will show
you the preview of that.
So I can click out
of this and say,
I want to move this
Python demo up.
This is just text,
this is not where
we are going to be
writing our Python
programs per se in this box.
Rather, we're going to come
down here to the start coding
or generate with AI,
we can just click Code
and it will create
these little text boxes.
So you'll see that in your
assignments and things,
I'll have a text
box and then we'll
write the Python program below.
So this is where I write
my Python program is I can
add code and then start typing.
So I can say, print Hello World.
That's the gateway to
being a programmer.
So if I say print Hello
World I press Run,
then it's going to output to me.
You can either say press Play
or you can say Control-Enter.
Mine's taking a second here, my
browser is being a little weird.
So it's just connecting.
And now it outputed
print to me Hello World.
So there you go.
There's your first
Python program.
Not too bad, but
there you have it.
So now I'll come back over here.
So you'll notice that we'll have
a variety of different syntax.
Syntax is rules that
govern a language.
So in order for us to
write Python program
and have it be interpretable,
again, by that compiler
that each programming
language has its own syntax,
again, those rules
that govern a language.
So the programming process
looks something like this.
We write a little bit of code,
this here's our flowchart.
We write a little
bit of code, we
test the code, we debug the
code, is the program complete?
If no, we loop back around.
If yes, then we end.
So is my program done?
Then yeah, and if not, keep
going, keep going keep going
and we're going to
loop back around.
But the idea here is to
write a little bit of code,
test the code, debug the
code, write a little bit code,
test the code, debug the code.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So some important
Python syntax rules.
Python cares a lot
about whitespace.
So indentation of code
lines is super important.
Python is case sensitive,
SQL is not, Python is.
Python does not
require semicolons
at the end of code lines
like many other programming
languages do.
Python allows for comments,
so commented outlines
are ignored by the
Python compiler.
Think of them like notes.
Good programmers,
which we're going
to be by the end of this
class, make extensive use
of code commenting.
They will say, this
is what I'm doing
the below lines, for example.
They remind you what
your code is doing
and help others figure
out what you're doing.
Oftentimes, like
in this class, you
are going to be working on
your own Python programs.
When you get into
industry, good chance
you're going to be collaborating
on certain Python programs.
If you're writing some
code and somebody else say,
Jill, your office partner
needs to look at your code,
and all of a sudden Jill is
like, I don't understand what's
going on here because
you're not commenting out
what you're trying to do.
How am I supposed to
help you troubleshoot?
That's not great practice.
So good programmers make
extensive use of commenting.
A Python comment
starts with a hashtag.
Programming also makes
extensive use of variables.
Now, before we jump
into variables,
let me show you what I
mean here by a comment.
So here I can double click
back into this program
I had written up above.
And let's say that I want to
write a comment above my print
Hello World.
I can say, I am printing
Hello World to my user.
Then I can do Control-Enter.
My program will run Hello World.
So this is a comment.
This is just commenting
out this line of code.
I can make notes of what
I'm doing throughout.
Perfect.
Programming also makes
extensive use of variables.
Variables are
containers for storing
data values, similar to what
we discussed in flowcharts when
we said, for example, we
looked at gross pay amount.
Gross pay was a
variable that we didn't
know the value of
that variable yet,
but it is a container
for storing data values.
Variables can be almost any
character, set of characters,
heavy on the almost.
Potential variable names
include X, name, my var,
whatever it may be.
They cannot start with a
number or contain certain other
characters.
So, for example, they can't
start with an asterisk,
they can't start with a
square bracket, what have you.
And they cannot be protected
words like false, as, if not,
we'll go through those.
There is different
variable types.
So a string is any type of text,
a float is any real number.
A float can be the 2.5 and an
integer is any whole number.
Then a text like hello
or like A for example.
Variables are created using
assignment statements.
So to assign a numeric
value to a variable,
we say my variable
equal to 7.53, oh,
that should be a
little arrow there.
Python will consider
my variable a float.
So it will autoassign based upon
how it interprets the variable's
value to be a float.
Other var right is equal to 8.
So Python will consider
other var an integer,
we also call them the ints.
To assign a text
value to a variable,
we say, saying
equals howdy partner
and then Python will consider
that saying a string.
We can assign the
value of one variable
to the value of
another variable,
and we can also
assign a variable
the value of a calculation.
So lots of variables
inside here.
So we're just going
to play around here.
So why don't I say my
name equal to Reagan.
So I'm declaring that variable
with my assignment statement.
So declaring the variable my
name, the value of that variable
is Reagan.
Now let's print out, print
my name, Control-Enter,
now it's going to print
the value of Reagan.
So I am printing the value
of the variable my name.
Now I can do this
in a different way,
say you don't need
to assign a variable,
but instead I can
just say print Reagan.
So in this instance, we're not
using this variable, my name,
we're using the literal value of
Reagan to print to my console.
So just keep that in mind.
If we are using a literal value,
the print has those parentheses,
we place whatever we want to
print within those parentheses,
and I want to print the
actual value Reagan.
Or I can print the value
from the variable, my name,
just as I did above.
So I'm going to delete these out
here, we're just playing around.
Now let's create a
little bit more code.
And let's say I want to
say that x is equal to 5.
Then we're going to say
that x, actually I'm
going to do this within
the same cell here,
we'll talk more about
these cells here in a bit,
but x is equal to 5.
Sorry, let's say that
y is equal to x plus x.
So x is equal to 5, y
is equal to x plus x.
So what do you think
the value of y is?
Well let's play this.
Oh, well, it didn't appear,
anything in my output
because I need to say print y.
So now I'll run this
and we'll say print y,
and that will print 10.
Now you notice here I'm in
different code blocks, that's
just fine because as long
as I ran this one then
this one will run.
But I'm going to try
and keep them all.
If we're talking about the same
program within the same code
block.
So I'll just keep this all
within the same code block.
Now when I run this, I see
that I have 10 output to me.
So this is where I'm
talking about when
I say that there's
assignment statements
and sometimes assignment
statements can say,
you know what, I
want the value of y
to be equal to the value of
the variable x plus the value
of the variable x, and
then I'm going to print y.
Awesome.
Again, to output something,
to print to the console,
for example, and
we'll talk a lot
about printing as we move on.
But this is a good place for us
to end this video here today.
Just looking at getting
into Google Colab,
running some Python,
and then we're
going to jump more
into printing inputs
if all the things to
do with programming.
But again, we're starting
from the ground up here.
We are just writing
programs that performs
a sequence of instructions.
Programming is an awesome way
to become a really good problem
solver.
Hey, thanks.
Take care, everybody.